he's looking for food and this rubbish
tip is worth one we'll get his next meal
he's just 11 years old
there's a flurry of excitement as he
spots something it's a bundle of notes
but even a brick of bolivars is
worthless Venezuelans are struggling
with annual inflation at two million
percent yes you did here right thousands
of starving and three million have fled
all of this to neighboring countries
including one's parents
he's now all alone fending for himself
my father is in Colombia and my mother
is in Peru so who you with who are you
living with alone along here how long
have you been alone full or quantity by
a tall so low too many years everything
edible they find is now precious but
even here on this dump
there's not a lot then a bag full of
leftover scraps is family it's putrid in
this heat the Flies are swarming all
over the box but the booth devoured
hunger makes for very few choices in
Venezuela and if you're a child all
alone it's just a question of survival
[Applause]
they're shouting for water most America
bows being hit by water shortages some
areas haven't had running water for two
years so they have to get it where they
can many here talk about the water
making them ill
there's been a breakdown of services
this is actually one of the waterways
now so clogged with rubbish you can
barely see the water a short distance
downstream we found more people
desperately trying to collect water it's
become a full-time job for many and many
here blame these problems on their
leader this guy needs to go Midori needs
to leave the country and the Venezuelans
will remain here if it's difficult in
the city it's a whole lot harder out in
the countryside
Erica's bringing up her three boys on
her own after her husband died four
months ago she's down to her last three
matches and lives from day to day
selling small cups of coffee
she makes less than a dollar a day
enough to buy two pieces of yucca and a
plantain this will be the only food she
and her boys eat today do you think
nicolas maduro should leave the
presidency
okay see Marcy mark what if I see a
single theme for the country yes Sara
nephew Sione Erika's boys sometimes do
this five times a day
all this in the country with the world's
largest oil reserves the poor used to be
the backbone of the venezuelan leaders
support but that support appears to be a
being away fast
Alex Crawford Sky News in Maracaibo
Venezuela